good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast jackie and i are so
thrilled and excited
to have an in-studio guest someone we've
been so excited to chat with
the reigning queen of realistic halls on
tick tock miss remy vader hello remy
welcome to the show
so happy to be here thank you for coming
of course
this is the most exciting thing like in
my life right now same
literally um you have had quite a year i
really have
can you take us back to pre-pandemic
what your life was like and then how all
this got started of course i can
so i was working well taking back a
little further
where when i met you guys at first i was
working at bravo tv right out of college
um i was doing pr didn't love it ended
up going into music
working at title which is jay-z's music
streaming service
um actually really did like it i was
doing partnership marketing there
and then unfortunately i lost my job i
was furloughed in
april of last year so like a year ago
and then i lost my job
in july because they said yes they were
like you're 100
coming back and then all the people that
were furloughed got let go wow
so at the time i was like losing my mind
yeah um
i was like what am i supposed to do
there was no jobs in like entertainment
marketing music like anything like that
yeah
so um my dad always worked in the
fashion industry he does women's jeans
and he like
always pushed me to do like plus size
modeling or just like fit modeling or
something
and i was like no i used to get offended
by it we're like that's like so
something that would offend me too
yeah like what the [ __ ] i was like
you're horrible and you've ruined my
life since childhood no that's literally
like the whole beginning of quarantine
like so
going back a little further like the
whole beginning of quarantine was like
when my weight
caught up to me from like i feel like i
was just i liked my job at title but i
was so
stressed all the time that i'd come home
and just like eat yeah and all my weight
caught up to me so that was a hard time
too because like
creep like beginning of the pandemic
being home with my family just like my
sister and my parents who like
i've always had a difficult very close
with them but when it comes to like food
and weight
yeah it's yeah so that was like a little
difficult so when my dad said that
it was just like it was over but instead
i was like you know what he really you
know
actually just was like trying to think
like what could i do because i can't sit
still like
doing nothing and laying in bed and
overthinking is horrible for me
i needed to work so he was like why
don't you just try to do fit modeling
for those who don't know fit modeling
is when you go into like the showroom or
something
and they just fit close on you you don't
even speak yeah but you make good money
the first season of summer house there
was a girl who was a fit model no
no hannah berner was a fit model oh but
there was someone else the first season
yeah she was a fit model and i'm like
damn she is so cute and she was a fit
model yeah i know what it is you so you
do have to be a specific like
like 10 inches smaller here to here but
you don't need
look like a mod like whatever so i was
like you know what i'll try
so i sent all of my like measurements
and my dad took pictures of me against a
white wall in my house and
it does sound so cute and we sent them
i sent them to all different modeling
agencies only heard back from one
and like basically signed with them in
august like pretty quickly they were
like
you're you'd be great as a fit model but
we also want you
as we could see you being like a model
mom yeah and i was like okay cool so
they called you pretty that's
yeah were like here and
um so then started doing that and then
nothing was happening
there was still no jobs really in
modeling unless you were doing it for a
long time like to be a new model in the
industry like no one
no so still losing my mind so then
in september like end of august i
started
which is just so funny now thinking
about it just like dming influencers
like
i wanna help you for free oh dm do you
guys
you would never know and
no no one ever saw why would people see
it like you know like you don't read
i can't read all of my messages from
everyone so like i dm'd like
probably like you i don't know like a
few like i say a handful
of people yeah and i was like i mean
honestly thank god no one answered yes
none of this would have happened yeah
yeah um so basically like jumping to how
all of this happened
i was like started getting a few fit
modeling jobs
and then i was like i need to do
something else so
i never was like loved tik tok actually
like during quarantine i wasn't like
scrolling all the time my sister was
obsessed with like let's do dances i'm
like i'm not doing dances looking like
this like i just refused um
so then i was i started finding more of
like that curvy fashion
stuff like videos on um tik tok
and i was like this is cool i feel like
i could do this maybe so i started
making a few videos like three videos
that were like
i made like three videos that were like
dress like
wait why can't i speak take your time
what um
i started making videos that were like a
celebrity look like like haley bieber
and a size 16. got it
no one saw them and like actually no i
was just about to say that sounds
familiar i feel like i've seen that
video no there i like
i got that from like that idea from
other creators i was like okay like a
bunch of people
are doing this like i could do it maybe
make it funny whatever but no one was
singing i was like oh my god
it takes so much time and effort to edit
yeah and do all this like i thought it
was crazy and i was like
kind of giving up on it and then one day
i got a package
from i don't know like nasty gal or
something and i always have done this
like i've always put on clothes
and like snapchatted my friends and been
like oh my god i look crazy like
i just would always think it was funny
and then i was like why don't i just
make like a tick tock of it
and it was truly for my friends and
that's the one that blew up
is that the one with your ass that was
like no that was like a few later
okay margo sent me that one and that's
how i discovered you and i was [ __ ]
cracking up when they took it down
because your ass was
yeah i was screaming when you commented
on it i was like oh my god and then it
was gone and i was like
like literally like in tears like i was
freaking out because that was like the
first one that blew up right
a lot of people saw it yeah it was so
funny that was the best video i ever did
because it like went viral like so
quick and it was going crazy and they
took it down so then i put on my
instagram
yeah and then you re-uploaded it it just
like covered your ass yeah that's funny
no but then yeah and then they kept
taking it down and it was just like
whatever yeah yeah
that's so annoying it was annoying but
that's kind of how i started doing the
the halls where i was like all right
people think i'm funny people think it's
relatable
and what if people don't know
what i do is kind of like get a large
amount of clothing from one brand
and then i try them on and some look
great and some look horrible
and i laugh about it and i talk about it
and i call them realistic halls
um and it just you know i think what
kept me doing it because it really is a
lot of work like in the
now i'm starting to work with some
brands other than that the realistic
calls are separate in itself
but when i go buy the clothes like i'm
buying those clothes i don't think
people realize yeah they think it's
expensive
yeah but if it is sponsored is there
then pressure to have like a positive
yes i'm trying to figure that out right
now but i don't really do realistic
calls with brands
yes so like i will keep the because in
the beginning
let's say i did the free people haul the
first one really blew up
and then they loved it and they sent me
sorry
and they sent me a bunch more clothes
and they were like you get to pick
so i was like okay great and they really
all looked good on me
yeah i didn't pretend they looked good
like it actually did
and then people were like going ham
being like now since free people is
working
no actually i can attest like as a
chubby person like the free people
clothing
a lot of my clothes are free people it's
like yeah very size inclusive and flowy
i love summing floating especially
especially that because it's flowy and
like they actually run i think a little
big some of the dresses and
stuff so also that's like a big part of
it too like
when i started doing this i never
thought of the brand i thought these
brands are going to hate me
but why did i i never thought this was
going to be my career so i didn't care
yeah and then actually a lot of the
brands started reaching out and being
like we love what you're doing like
let's send you clothes i'm not stupid of
course the brands obviously
want me to find things i like and post
positive about them but at least they're
acknowledging it yeah like that's what i
appreciate
we're now a year out from you losing
your job and this is your full-time job
correct
yes you pay your bills yes this is crazy
full-time job
i do the modeling more part-time because
i just don't do it as much and it kind
of like
does come into this as well um i signed
with uta
so i'm working with them for more of
like my brand
deals and stuff that i'm assigned to
modeling agency as well so
but i would say this like this takes up
all of my time yeah of course
um and you know like yesterday i did
videos the whole entire day i'm editing
them myself
doing everything and does having this
huge presence on social media help you
book modeling gigs
yes that's the thing like i really
wasn't getting any like i
i almost felt like inauthentic being
like i'm a curve model and i was like
wait i'm not getting any jobs this is
awkward
yeah like i swear like i did my first
test shoot then i kept posting the test
shoot pictures and like people
definitely are catching on oh my god
that is so funny like you hadn't booked
a gig yet
like i did that for so long that i was i
think about everything so i
think which is good and bad but i was
like oh my god this is embarrassing but
now
i'm like starting to get like i just did
a big free people shoot in
santa barbara with very stunning yeah
and it was just
stunning yeah thank you stunning um that
was like super last minute and they just
like
i don't know what's it and you know and
that's another thing too a lot of people
are very positive and then there'll be
people that
where there's always negative people but
that will be like well don't you feel
like these brands are just using you as
like they're one token plus size girl
and i'm like
they're that's something though i don't
know let's say they are like
i have bills to pay [ __ ] off yeah and
that's you like people take a moral high
ground on like the fact that like you
need to work
like yeah it's so silly try like i it
must be difficult being thrust like
i think a lot of people grow their brand
online and it takes time but you just
kind of like blew up in like
six months um and it can be overwhelming
to have that many people's opinions of
you being shared with you on an everyday
basis
yeah curious how you internalize that
yeah it's a lot and i really feel like
on some days i genuinely don't care and
like
i'm choosing to put also like my body in
front of the camera and things that i'm
not happy about like
i always say i don't thank you i don't
consider myself
a body positive influencer people like
to say that i'm not offended by that and
i think
people who are body positive influencers
that's great i feel like i would just
call myself like a realistic influencer
because like i am not super happy with
my body right now like i gained like 50
something pounds it's
this year no it's like we're body
positive for other people yeah
yeah and in my opinion we still hate
ourselves
my thing is more like but i'm not gonna
hide in my room like i did do this time
last year
yeah and when i started gaining the
weight and would go to work every day
and pants that didn't fit and be so
uncomfortable and just like
not want to talk to boys anywhere like
i'm not i still feel a little those
things
but this tick tock changed me in a
positive way and
tick tock changed me in the best way
possible because of all the people
because of all the positive things
people are saying like people reminded
me of things that i forgot about myself
and i still will be like i posted a
video the other day and i'm like i'm
having a bad day like
i'm realizing that like i made a video a
few months ago saying like you can't let
your weight
not have you not allow you to go on
dates but like that's a hundred percent
what i'm doing yeah and until i feel
fully comfortable i don't really want to
well that's you're not hypocrite like
yeah why at least you're not a hypocrite
like yeah you're owning the fact that
you are contradicting yourself
yes and like i feel like that's just how
i've like i feel like the remy i'm
putting on social media no matter what
any haters want to say or not who have
never known me my friends my family
everyone who has is like i
love this for you because it's the remy
you've always been and that's exactly
who i've been like sometimes i say
stupid [ __ ] and then i'm just like
why did i say that so i'm just then i'll
make a video following up with that
so what i'm learning is that maybe i
don't need to do it with
everything like i don't need to say all
of my feelings yes
um because sometimes then it's just
gonna kind of go back in your face that
gives you more of a platform
for people to be negative to criticize
yeah
so i'm but i'm learning all this like
you said like literally this has been
like i think eight months like this is
just like
why would i ever think when i started
this that this would be what it was and
even uh four months ago i would say like
i was refusing
to not go back into like marketing or
something and everyone was like remy
like
you need to go with this and i'm like i
can't like i built this resume since
11th grade like i can't
not go with it yeah yeah well i think
that's like a hard thing for a lot of
people is like it feels
like in the influencer space it's kind
of uncertain yes and even though
you might be making more money than you
do with a traditional job that
traditional job just gives you a sense
of stability
yeah and a lot of people don't want to
let that go once they become yes and
then of course i have my parents
or you know close friends too just like
well what if it did
all fall apart and i'm like thank you
you've been saying that to me since
2016. you're gonna be fine yeah so i'm
just like you know what i at least do
i really do have a lot of experience in
a resume and i'm
pretty sure that i could figure it out
yeah yeah but you gotta ride the wave
yeah and i'm like like now i've let that
go like now i'm like wait now i can't
even picture myself going into an office
doing that which is crazy because
i was very much like how can i not have
a routine and
live this life but now this is my life
and yeah and i do like it i wake up
happier every day compared to how i did
going into an office every day and like
i thought i was happy but i wasn't yeah
so i want to continue doing this and
aside from everything and just all the
like fame and the followers like i'm
genuinely helping people every single
day which like makes it so much more
worth it but the game in the followers
doesn't hurt either yeah that's great
also
i would argue it's just as good it
tastes so sweet so sweet
where are your favorite places to shop
since you're kind of an expert in like
who has what i went to h m because you
did an h m hall and i have to say
like it didn't do it for me but yeah no
it's very hit or miss
any of those stores are hit or miss like
i found like
a shirt at forever 21 from that hall
that i loved and then everything else i
returned right yeah
um right now like this tops reformation
i think they have like really great
did i not just say that jackie yeah no
reformation has great extended sizing
yeah and it's really cute and this isn't
this is like older this is from last
year or something maybe it doesn't fit
me correctly
um but i realized that when i walked in
here but
they now have extended sizing and they
make it like very i don't know i love
that because like i
my whole point of even doing all this is
like i want to be trendy too and yes
there's always been like plus size
stores and stuff but maybe sometimes not
the trendiest
and like we should be able to wear
whatever we want
yeah i think there's this misconception
that if you're shopping in extended
sizing like you're 97 years old because
yeah only things they sell are like
cheetah print moomoos
and it's like we deserve like body suits
as well exactly so that's why a lot of
like what i mean i just post my style
but a lot of what i wear is like
sexy body shoes i like to show like this
part of my stomach or like certain
things like that so
i mean honestly i really have been
liking free people lately
i'm a huge abercrombie gal oh
yes a lot of people like and my
followers are like i can't do it because
they ruined my childhood because i grew
up
like i couldn't either in my sister word
all the time but like
again anyone who's making the effort now
i'm gonna give a chance and they like
really promote their curvy line and
everything and then they have like
trendy cool clothes too like
great body suits like i'm a fan you just
need a size
one full size up got it got it my
favorite haul that you did was revolve
like i was crying laughing like i'm here
to go to surf lodge
not in that outfit like i was literally
laughing so hard that's
me trying to get into a club um what are
your thoughts yeah
honor of all yeah um we talk about that
a lot we talk about it a lot because
like i shop at revolve but
you know i like let's say when i'm
shopping i refine by size
so it's like okay i'm shopping rompers 5
000 rompers i need anything a large
or an extra large 25 can we cut this out
really quick can you say something yeah
sure promise yeah
yeah um just because i feel like you
need to know with us okay so starting a
line with them
fabulous so i'm like how do i know i
should know how to work it out no no we
don't have to but
i'm starting their first inclusive line
and i was going to tell you this
afternoon because i want to send you
guys that stuff
that comes out um but they really
were i was like at first like didn't
hear a word and i was like screw them
because brandon
before they didn't say anything and they
were like we've been waiting to do this
we didn't know the right time like we
want to do like revolving yeah
i mean it was like holy [ __ ] wow that's
amazing so yeah i very much was like no
screw them at first but i think if any
if it was a brandy melville
no i wouldn't do no but honestly anyone
who wants to do it revolve has just like
been really dragging their feet
yeah it's just like 21. and i think it
can be announced
hopefully like soon like it's like and
then and then
yeah and then it'll be in fall but um
we could still talk like i could just
say yeah but i just want to like let you
got it okay so as a question again yeah
what are your thoughts
i think that they are not super
inclusive they know that
um i mean i think they know that and
um their clothes are a little expensive
which is what i said in my haul too
i think they need to make changes and
i'm like hoping that they do
they were one of the brands too that
like liked my haul and said it was great
wanted to send me some clothes you know
and like i always say like hoping
you know like this makes some sort of
change or whatever um
but they're one of like the five or six
brands i would say that has reached out
after a hall
that appreciated it and said like we're
working on making changes so like i gave
them that
yeah of course um but yeah like none of
those clothes really fit me and then and
then i found like you know one blazer
that was
an xl that was like beautiful and i wear
all the time like and i think that's
with any place but the point is
it's like now or never to me it's like
okay i'll give you guys a chance now but
like all of these
if you're seeing this if you're seeing
all of these comments from people on tik
tok instagram youtube whatever like
take it do something with it because if
you don't now you're gonna be the one
left out like and like yes it's crazy
that it's 20 21 and like a lot of these
brands haven't done it
but like it hasn't been this talked
about like i feel like body positivity
stuff
started when like a few years ago more
but like now with tick-tock like it's
just like going
crazy yeah and talking about the actual
brands and doing these reviews that are
blowing up that like
the brands need to not be stupid and
just need to listen yeah no and it's
honestly like just a good
marketing move like you'll reach more
people yes like why wouldn't you want
that
more and that's what i don't you know i
think i'll never understand that it's
like
i there was one brand i was doing like a
fitting for and i was just like for bras
or something and i was just like so why
you know don't you have bigger sizes i'm
just wondering and she was going into
how like it's them
me you know what's more expensive which
it is to make the product and do all
that and it's more material and they
want to structure it right like also bs
because like
you're going to make more money if you
sell tomorrow what are your thoughts on
like extended sizing costing more than
like a size small like
like an xl costing more than a medium
in the store online or in stores like
i've seen that in many stores you know i
actually really haven't like noticed
that
i should i should that's my core no
that's great i should really like
look into that because i never really
noticed that
are you saying if it's the same like
piece yeah yeah like the same shirt in
like
yeah i'm guessing it's just because
it's like more material they're putting
into it that's horrible yeah
but that's a good callout yeah thank you
claudia you're welcome um
well you have had really just like an
amazing year what do you think
like is is next for remy b
um what is next i
you know i like i'm so excited about
like everything that's happening i
actually like keep saying yes to so many
things like i i need to figure out what
it is i want to do and i don't think i
need to figure that out at the moment
i think again we've talked about how
like i never knew this would happen
so i've always seen myself doing so many
things that i was like
well this is a nice dream but it's never
going to happen right so now i have like
the ability to do so many things that i
just want to make the right choices and
i'm kind of like going slow with it like
you know like
oh free people reaching out to do a
modeling shoot like cool
sure you know like so i'm kind of you
know
i would like to maybe do like something
tv related one day
um like more like hosting thing not like
acting or like
um you know i love to sing am i gonna be
a singer no but i'd like to like plug
that into something like i just like
want to like
do things that make me happy and like
keep showing myself but to the
and keep showing myself to the world but
at the same time like i think the
helping
people is so important and like that i
think long long term i'd love to have
like a
remy line that's like truly my own or
something i think that's like
longer term but that's like every little
piece of like
this what what i talk about and like
what i feel like we need
and like give that to all of my
followers so beautiful
that remy that's beautiful um can you
tell everyone where to follow you
and thirst out for a minute yeah your
platforms um
it's just at remy bader
r-e-m-i-b-a-d-e-r and it's on
and i'm on tick-tock and instagram
fabulous love to see it
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you guys for listening we hope you
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you guys